[Musik]
die demokratie steht in flammen von
einem tag auf den anderen stirbt in
myanmar die hoffnung auf ein leben in
freiheit und gerechtigkeit
auch friedensnobelpreisträgerin aung san
suu kyi sitzt erneut in haft es beginnt
ein kampf um leben und tod
[Musik]
mittendrin steht plötzlich auch die
schweizer diplomatin christine schraner
burgener
als sonderbotschafterin der uno wird sie
zur letzten hoffnung der bevölkerung in
mir mal ein fast alleine kämpft sie mit
willen und worten gegen die waffen der
militärs
fast ein jahr lang begleite ich die
top-diplomaten in ihrem unermüdlichen
kampf gegen thomas militär shooter es
wird eine reise von bern über bangkok
und berlin bis zur uno in new york
[Musik]
es war ein kurzes für mamas demokratie
nach zehn jahren freiheit reißt die
armee am ersten februar 20 21 die macht
wieder an sich buchstäblich hinter dem
rücken des volkes lassen die generäle
die panzer aufrollen die welt ist
schockiert burma ist nicht länger die
vorzeige demokratie in südostasien
myanmar wie das land auch genannt wird
steht vor einem scherbenhaufen und eine
schweizerin versucht verzweifelt zu
vermitteln es war ein schreckliches
erwachen heute für die menschen in burma
nach zehn jahren fortschritt ein voll
stopp internet und telefon funktionieren
auf einmal nicht mehr das militär hat
alles abgeschaltet doch ganz
überraschend kam dieser kuh nicht
schockierend war aber trotzdem auch für
mich der seit jahren über die region
berichtet ein gespräch mit top
diplomaten burgener lässt böses ahnen
strophen will es wird das land wieder
zurück auf die zeit vor
eine isolation von einer landwirtin
hauptamt 38 korn
jetzt ist es wieder soweit es folgten
tage des protests der verunsicherungen
und der wut vor allem die junge
generation kämpft friedlich um das zarte
pflänzchen der demokratie
[Musik]
hallo
weit weg vom burmesischen yang gon im
beschaulichen bern laufen in den tagen
des bangens die drähte hals nicht etwa
im bundeshaus sondern in der wohnung der
familie schraner burgener
es ist ein wiedersehen nach langer zeit
wir kennen uns aus den jahren als sie
botschafterin war ein thailand und sind
mittlerweile per du
2018 wurde die sonderbotschafterin für
die uno seither habe sie nie mehr
gesehen um ihre arbeit nicht zu
gefährden mit die diplomatin den kontakt
zu journalisten
der akku hat nun alles verändert
ich glaube es ist wirklich wichtig zu
sagen dass man das verurteilen und dass
ich normal wird möglichst schnell mit
amerika will ich jetzt anscheinend immer
noch fast die einzige womit armina
kontakte in der kleinen wohnung wo sie
mit ihrem mann und ihrem sohn lebt wird
gerade weltpolitik gemacht die pandemie
zwingt die diplomatin ins home office
wochen lang zieht sie von hier in bern
die fäden zwischen mir und dem rest der
welt
die uno hofft dass die botschaft drin so
bald wie möglich nach myanmar reisen
kann um dort die generäle zu treffen
ich wiederhole meinen aufruf an die
militärregierung der sondergesandten un
botschafterin christine schraner
burgener zugang zu myanmar zu gewähren
immer mehr beschäftigte das schicksal
auch die großen player der weltbühne die
geplante reise der uno botschafterin
nach myanmar wird zunehmend zu einer
delikaten geopolitischen frage trat am
liebsten mit dem uno-generalsekretär
telefoniert und gesagt weit normalität
angekommen zum ganze für sie dass die da
mit chinesen am gleichen strick ziehen
und jetzt manhard und jetzt fertig abruf
new york aber will ich gefunden habe
dann gleich wo sie das dann adam j armee
seit mai und sport oder damit gibt es
eigentlich mal wenigstens schon mal auf
thailand noch sitzt sie in bern fest
fünf wochen sind vergangen seitdem kuh
und manchmal kommen wut und zweifel auf
das lüd werden langsam mutiger oder eine
wird hat sich jetzt macht sich breit er
will wissen dass die tiere sind das ja
ein prozess wurde jetzt drei jahre lang
als friedensprozess prozess begleitete
jetzt plötzlich
extrem ruhig oder verglüht
um dann charmant einfach nur verrückt
ich probiere immer
emotionen kontrollieren von mir selber
will das braucht energie und das ist
das motto in ganz japan setzen
negative gedanken und dienst nimmt
energie von einem hektar bin ich
überzeugt und darum probiere ich immer
wieder sage okay fokussiert auf das was
ich mache und space stoppte zwar den
kopf hängen lassen liegt nicht drin wenn
burmas demokratie wieder blühen soll
es sind lange tage
nach telefonkonferenzen von yang gon bis
new york steht heute noch ein auftritt
in der talk sendung club beim schweizer
fernsehen an wir fahren nach zürich und
haben zeit über unsere gemeinsamen jahre
in thailand zu sprechen wenn er zum
beispiel wichtig sehr schmuck sie meinen
teil auch sie
sind das sache wo du jetzt
in thailand
vermittler
und das habe ich auch keine im stile
machen wie man die stille diplomatie
haben die leute sie bietet jedem start
bietet und das ist jetzt ganz anders
will ich jetzt in der öffentlichkeit
bekannt bin und dass sie spielerisch
wieder habe ich erklärt vieles wie zum
beispiel bei klimaverhandler wie beim
usa
und vor allem
geostrategisch
vaillant arena
da habe ich einfach pflichten und
wir sind in zürich gleich beginnt die
aufzeichnung der talksendung christine
schraner burgener soll über ihre
erfahrungen mit diktaturen rechten noch
vor der sendung kriegen wir eine
kostprobe wie unberechenbar solche
regime sein können es ist eine
beunruhigende nachricht aus mer mal die
polizei hat das büro der lokalen
mitarbeiter umziehen
sofort alarmiert burgener das
sicherheitsteam der uno in new york
ich bin sehr besorgt sie haben eine
nachricht geschickt die polizei sei beim
haus ich befürchte dass die reinkommen
sie fragen ob sie telefon und laptop
zerstören sollen
es bestreichen bei mir minuten
[Applaus]
und dann die erlösende nachricht
ich konnte nicht rangehen ich war auf
dem dach um laptop und hilde von zu
verstecken
yahoo
es sind solche momente die schraner
burgener antreiben weiterzumachen
noch einmal kurz durchatmen und schon
beginnt die sendung
[Musik]
die
richtige schauenburger
uno-sonderbeauftragte für burma sie seit
in burma passiert massiv die
menschenrechtsverletzungen die
protestanten führungen und militärputsch
im februar weg sei das haben der betrug
bei der parlamentswahl oder direkt an ob
selbst sie versuchen noch nie amazon
verhandle jetzt hätte oder
sicherheitsgurte statement los hier mit
der
präsident steht er begrüße wenn sie
nicht reisen aus linz
woche
stattgefunden hat mit der army
telefoniert und am herd drei stunden
video conference call of duty kommandos
oder nummer zwei der armee und ich eine
rückfrage ich möchte eigentlich so rasch
wie möglich hoch und ein zeitnahes sechs
monaten und mit punkt sie müssen und die
suche gemacht aber gewalt betrug und
dann wählen sie audio das movement also
die bewegung der zivile ungehorsam oder
dass die heißt sie will dieser bietet
das movement wählen sie bei anderen mit
anderen worten sind einfach gut von der
straße weg und dann hatte ich dann
probanden situation noch ein friedliches
ende doch friedlicher wird die situation
nicht
drei wochen später ist es soweit die
sonderbotschafterin fliegt erstmals seit
dem putsch nach asien zuerst allerdings
nur nach thailand denn nach wie vor
wollen sie die burmesischen generäle
nicht ins land lassen
offizieller grund ist die pandemie
ich
meine ich wäre schon lang im juni corona
will dann brauche ich gar nicht der
bewilligung zum ihre einzel will ich
habe ja sowieso
morgen muss ich mich frage ob jetzt
endlich
die pandemie ist eine willkommene
ausrede für die generäle ganz abbrechen
wollen sie den kontakt aber nicht
sie haben ja publiziert
verärgert sind die generäle vor allem
über den klartext den schraner burgener
spricht und dass sie die
menschenrechtsverletzungen und
gräueltaten an parma vor ort in burma
hat sich die lage in der zwischenzeit
zugespitzt das militär demonstriert ganz
unverfroren seine wiedererlangte macht
die uno spricht vom blutigsten tag seit
dem putsch anfang februar
vor wenigen tagen haben soldaten auf
demonstranten geschossen
mindestens 90 zivilisten kamen dabei ums
leben entspannung ist keine in sicht die
vom volk so geliebte demokratie ikone
aung san suu kyi hat nichts mehr zu
sagen seitdem sitzt sie in haft die
friedensnobelpreisträgerin war auch für
christine schraner burgener arbeit eine
wichtige figur bis zum putsch hatten die
beiden regelmäßig kontakt
mit der schlüsselfigur mit anfangs
versucht kontakte was sich dazwischen
passiert wie gott sie etwas was weiß ich
weiß jetzt vom
arbeitsmarkt virtueller aber eher aktien
aktiv räte aber das sind eher kurz gar
jetzt noch mehr anwalt engagiert im
ganzen sache
also 70 habe durfte und ich lerne dazu
sage ich wenn ich sehe dass man jetzt
auch nie im letzten moment gekommen ist
schrieben armee geschickt und seit mitte
2010 wie lange schraner burgener in
asien bleibt ist offen sie rechnet mit
bis zu zwei monaten ihr job als uno
botschafterin verlangt viel flexibilität
von
open
stück weg sie
unterstützt die kampagne von
morgen und noch mal also extra nochmals
deutlich machten die lehrerschaft
verletzt
das ist das ziemlich glücklich
[Gelächter]
ziel der reise nach asien ist ein
treffen mit den generälen die diplomatin
hofft die militärs mit gesprächen doch
noch zum umdenken zu bewegen sei es mit
argumenten oder mit dem druck von
sanktionen
die erfolgschancen sind jedoch gering
die reise nach bangkok ist auch eine
reise zurück in die eigene vergangenheit
bangkok war ihre erste stelle als
botschafterin für die schweiz und es gab
noch ein anderes nun zum ersten mal
schickte die eidgenossenschaft ein paar
im job-sharing auf einen außenposten
alle welt spricht von jobsharing die
schweiz spricht nicht nur darüber sie
macht es der welt vor und geht völlig
neue diplomatische wege in der schweizer
botschaft in thailand teilt sich seit
freitag nämlich ein ehepaar den
botschafterposten pascal nufer hat das
teilzeitbeschäftigten paar einen tag
lang in bangkok begleitet
seit freitag sind sie im amt die beiden
neuen botschafter in thailand das
ehepaar bogener straner zu zweit teilen
sie sich eine stelle die bis anhin von
einer person betreut wurde
zehn tage sind vergangen seit ihrem
abflug aus zürich 10 tage die schraner
burgener in quarantäne verbrachte und
zeit hatte möglichst viele treffen zu
organisieren
wichtig ist uns nach richards sind ja
zuerst
alles gute
berlin
[Musik]
wichtig ist ja auch ein besuch an ihrem
ehemaligen arbeitsort der schweizer
botschaft in bangkok
[Musik]
das ist einfach fantastisch und sehr
sehr spannend damals in ihr tun und auch
sie
dann oder militärputsches vom forscher
her absolut spannende zeit und natürlich
war da sagte axel schmidt der familie wo
gegangen sind und jetzt ja immer die
hier wohnen
doch es geht nicht nur um erinnerungen
im zentrum steht auch hier die situation
in japan
wir werden noch viel über die situation
der geflüchteten sprechen und haben uns
schon mit dem urin hcr getroffen
ihr wissen über die region kommt er
diplomat ihm jetzt zugute
ihre kontakte öffnen ihr auch heute noch
viele türen
sie trifft uno-vertreter diplomaten
menschenrechtsorganisationen und
journalisten immer mit dem ziel eine
gemeinsame strategie zu finden um die
generelle doch noch zum einlenken zu
bringen
auf dem weg zur amerikanischen botschaft
gerät der lokale mitarbeiter der
diplomat ihn regelrecht ins schwärmen
die sondergesandte ist eine super
diplomaten und eine außergewöhnliche
mentorin es ist ein privileg
ihr arbeitsethos ist unglaublich sie
arbeitet 20 stunden am tag
wir versuchen mitzuhalten und
unterstützen sie wo es geht
amerika spielt eine wichtige rolle in
mir mal zu diesem besuch geht die
sonderbotschafterin allein journalisten
sind nicht zugelassen
die zeit vergeht wie im fluge es ist
bereits mai in lima ist keine
entspannung in sicht
christine schraner burgener ist immer
noch in asien
in einem video interview zieht sie für
die tagesschau zwischenbilanz
konnte doch gewisse treffen vom gesicht
zu gesicht macht nun nicht nur virtuell
und man kann so auch besser
vertraulichkeiten austauschen bei der
zwischenzeit gelang ihr ein kleiner
durchbruch sie konnte nach jakarta
fliegen und tatsächlich den burmesischen
general treffen war ich die einzige die
ein bilaterales treffen mit ihm halten
kommt ja so alle anderen haben ist in
asien verbund gemacht und so konnte ich
ihm eigentlich auch viel mehr sagen was
uns bedrückt was wo wir einen korb ist
ein sprechen
doch trotz des gesprächs bleiben die
aussichten düster die diplomatin darf
nicht einreisen und sitzt weiter fest
die einzige möglichkeit burmesische
zivilisten zu treffen bietet sich
schließlich in bangkok eine gruppe
geflüchtet journalisten wie die
sonderbotschafterin in einem geheimen
haus empfangen aus angst vor
repressionen haben sie sich nach dem
putsch nach thailand abgesetzt jetzt
beobachten sie die situation aus toughen
die journalistin hoffen dass die uno
sonderbotschafterin auch ihre situation
weiter tragen kann was ist denn für sie
die größte herausforderung
[Musik]
es sind solche treffen für die christine
schraner burgener ihren job liebt
ich finde mich haben vieles delegieren
gerne teamplayer
gehör
[Musik]
der weg zum frieden in mir bleibt
steinig trotz aller bemühungen bleibt
der sonderbotschafterin ein zugang zum
land weiterhin verwehrt
fast ein halbes jahr ist vergangen seit
dem besuch in bank die situation hat
sich kaum verändert in berlin treffen
wir christine schraner burgener wieder
hier war sie schweizer botschafterin
bevor sie den job bei der uno annahme
bald endet ihr mandat die letzten wochen
als sonderbotschafterin haben begonnen
das noch optisch ist das café jetzt ja
eigentlich gehe das heißt man immer noch
chancen noch einen drauf der weg zu
demokratie sicherlich zu finden
hallo
karachis team
viele wäre mir auch am brandenburger tor
und danach wieder kraft tanken
bevor sie ihre tochter die hier in
berlin studiert treffen kann wartet ein
mit terminen vollgepackter tag auf die
diplomatin vom deutschen auswärtigen amt
bis hin zum schweizer botschafter selbst
über mittag ist die uno-sondergesandte
eingespannt und hält noch kurz einen
vortrag ihre zunehmender enttäuschung
über die lage in japan wird immer
spürbarer
weil jetzt beide seiten wollen nicht
aufgeben das ist aber auch gleichzeitig
eine hoffnung und das ist eben die
hoffnung für die kinder im jama dass sie
nicht eine lost generation werden
sondern dass wir das rad noch umdrehen
können mit ihm saal sitzt auch ein alter
weggefährte paul seger er ist heute
schweizer botschafter in berlin und war
zuvor selber drei jahre botschafter im
jama
situation der bund ist wirklich sehr
sehr sehr schwierig sein sondern ist
zumindest haben bei personen mit
christine schorn aber mit ihrem ganzen
iss besucht schlimmstes verhört der
dialog womöglich als plage und vor allem
es gab sehr wichtig ist auf irland und
hütet und
international die unterstützungs
mobilisieren der tag ist gut gelaufen am
brandenburger tor wird christine
schraner burgener bereits von ihrer
tochter erwartet sofort wird das der
top-diplomat ihn eine stolze mutter
ja ja ja ja auch ich kenne tochter
justine noch aus der zeit in bangkok
[Gelächter]
durch ihre diplomaten laufbahn ist
christine schraner burgener viel in der
welt herumgekommen immer in begleitung
ihrer familie und audi ist sei auch sie
zu hause
das ist wirklich so passiert sind oder
ist dass
christine schraner burgener muss zurück
nach bern um ihre letzte reise für die
uno vorzubereiten
ein allerletztes mal fliegt sie nach new
york an den hauptsitz der uno
christine schraner burgener ist im
endspurt ihrer zeit als sondervermittler
in der vereinten nationen im jama ist
derweil kein ende der gewaltherrschaft
in sicht
schlacht die magics ivo verhaftet worden
er bekommt die chance nummer zwei vor
den medien smith mit bewegung und
dann sofort
probiert roland schlager aber
anscheinend ist schlimmste passiert dass
er hat in der nacht erschienen
sofort wurde das jetzt im koma liegt im
spital und mehr probiert aber es ist
natürlich extrem schlimm solche
meldungen gehen hier auch nach monaten
intensiver arbeit noch nach sie sind der
beweis dafür dass selbst
spitzendiplomaten wenig ausrichten
können gegen skrupellose generelle es
schmerzt christine schraner burgener
dass sie nicht mehr erreichen konnte für
die bühne singen und lesen
bringt
zu
hause kaffee wir immer noch
vorsichtig da mal ein paar unterschiede
macht eine frühere bevor bevor es
ist zeit abschied zu nehmen von new york
aber auch von mir mal das hier im
central park kaum weiter weg sein können
dreieinhalb jahre hat die
sonderbotschafterin vergebens versucht
dem land demokratie zu bringen was
bleibt ist ein scherbenhaufen und
erinnerungen erinnerungen an das land
der goldenen pagoden ein land das
geprägt ist von hall und kulturen burma
wie man das land früher nannte ist auch
ein land das immer wieder mit seiner
geschichte habe denken
zb mit der geschichte der muslimischen
minderheit der rohingya auch für diese
setzte sich schraner burgener immer
wieder ein wie hier bei einem besuch für
die uno 2018
es sind aber auch erinnerungen an noch
frühere zeiten und 2012 zum beispiel als
man an eine große zukunft glaubte für
mir mal die schweiz gehörte zu den
ersten ländern die dort im beisein des
damaligen außenministers eine neue
botschaft eröffneten
das ist ein neustart für die beziehungen
zwischen der schweiz und myanmar myanmar
kann jetzt die menschenrechte
wiederentdeckt es kann seine wirtschaft
zum blühen bringen und an diesem
historischen moment wollen wir teilhaben
der erste schweizer botschafter von mir
war damals kein anderer als christine
schraner burgener aus mann christoph
burgener
moment für die bilateralen beziehungen
zwischen der schweiz und sicherlich auch
für mich das gebe ich zu ich bin sehr
stolz der rest der resident
erwirtschafte hier in myanmar zu sein
die aufbruchstimmung war wie bewältigen
man glaubte an demokratie freiheit und
ein wirkliches ende einer
schreckensherrschaft
meine frau christine wunderschöne danke
so wie ich
er ist auch sehr bescheiden
[Gelächter]
all dies liegt heute weit zurück ein
weiteres mal versinkt das land der
goldenen pagoden in den dunklen schatten
der diktatur
zurück in new york
christine schraner burgener ist auf der
zielgeraden ihrer umlaufbahn es bleibt
noch eine woche um ihr mandat als
sonderbotschafterin abzuschließen war
ein letztes mal alt die
spitzendiplomaten von termin zu termin
nach dreieinhalb jahren ist das problem
immer noch die macht des militärs
sind tage des abschieds und des
zurückschauen zum abschluss trifft sie
ein letztes mal ihren chef den
uno-generalsekretär
antonio guterres
sie gehen nun also zurück nachdem ja
ich bin sehr traurig
[Musik]
leider ist heute ein trauriger tag
wir müssen abschied nehmen von einer
ordentlichen botschafter in der uno
sie hat einen fantastischen job
geleistet für die menschen in myanmar
sie haben dort enorm von ihren mut und
ihre entschlossenheit und ihren
prinzipien profitiert
aber auch die uno hat unglaublich von
ihr profitiert alle die mit der myanmar
krise zu tun haben respektieren unsere
arbeit dank der leistung unserer
exzellenten sonderbotschafterin
[Musik]
niemand hätte diese arbeit besser machen
können als christin müssen wir ohne sie
zurecht kommen
schöne worte doch die realität ist
bitter auch eine uno sonderbotschafterin
ist machtlos gegenüber der willkür einer
runter schraner burgener zieht weiter
sie wird jetzt die erste chefin des
staatssekretariats für migration der
schweiz
ich danke
reise wie leben
migrationspolitik hat da willst du mit
dem ausland
und so werden ihre reisen von nun an
wohl etwas kürzer werden sicher ist auch
in ihrem neuen job wird er die arbeit
nicht ausgehen